aanu what a wonderful performance what
was it like for you though taking this
on and did you use the book as well as
the screenplay to develop this what was
your process I would say the Brilliance
of Miss wilkerson's writing is that she
is a very personal and intimate writer
and I saw cast as a historical work
journalistic work but for me is it is as
much a memoir as anything else and so I
was able to search for those clues about
the woman in every page because her
blood runs through every word every page
she personalizes everything so I yes I
studi the great script that I had but my
Bible also was was cast the book